[MUSIC].
We have all 12 teams paired up, ready to
go.
[MUSIC].
The reason we teach sales in the MBA
curriculum is because in the real world of
business there are two types of problems.
>> So this is actually the most critical
round.
You either put yourself on a trajectory to
win or you end up in a hole that you
spend all the rest of your time trying to
dig your way out.
Oh, no.
>> Not enough orders, and everything else.
>> Team 10 has submitted.
>> And this sales class, it's about not
enough orders.
[MUSIC].
>> So they probably took my advice to
heart, and I always tell people show up.
With your first move already planned out.
>> We created the game to teach
forecasting, so that we
get a bad forecast and we can show them
the problems with getting a good forecast.
That was the whole purpose of doing this
thing.
>> Levers.
Essentially what they have to do is they
have to make three decisions.
They first of all have to figure out what
their sales goal is going to be.
Then they have to set quota across three
different regions.
And the final decision personnel.
How many sales managers and
how many reps are you going to deploy to
these regions to make your quota?
>> All we have to decide is...
>> We try to create in a simulation the
environment in the sales floor, so
it's very interesting.
We're gonna judge you on how much you
make, and how much you book,
and how successful you are and by the way
we want you to forecast, and
we do this thing and all of a sudden the
class is on fire.
>> Okay, the assignment, so let's, let's,
let's agree to come in position.
[INAUDIBLE] to go.
Is that cool?
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> Blood comes up.
People get really excited about competing
in this thing.
>> Why would you be like [CROSS-TALK].
>> We didn't know we were gonna get that
effect, and when we got it,
it was just gravy for us.
It was really good.
>> I have a maximum of ten minutes.
To read the results, and do additional
analysis, modify their budgets,
and then submit a feasible plan.
[MUSIC].
And now they've only got about six minutes
left.
Students get to decide what roles they
play.
Yeah.
Are they done?
Send them all for coffee and tell them we
will meet them back in the classroom.
[MUSIC].
>> What we are going to do is we're going
to go on
from here to have a discussion with these
teams.
We're gonna find out what strategies the
winners and the losers deploy.
How did you decide what decisions you
would make?
Who you would hire?
Where you would deploy the resources.
What number you would shoot for?
And how you would make that number?
We started set an initial quote of 85
million.
hm.
And hit 112 in the first quarter.
So, what we were doing was.
Let's try and spend less up front and make
sure that our reps hit quota and
didn't quit.
>> Wow, yes, team three.
>> That sounded almost identical to our
strategy.
Our target was like 86 million and we
tried to not over allocate to central and
we just missed badly.
So, I think this is actually good to talk
about once we get into some of
the consequences.
I think it's important to understand where
these kind of strategies,
where they don't pan out as you expect.
>> In addition to solving the forecasting
problem which we did,
we created an environment where.
>> Pretty big differences in the.
>> MBAs here.
Have an opportunity to feel what it's like
to
be in a group of people where you get
judged by your numbers as you perform.
So, so long as we're going to pretend Rio,
we'll go at carnival time.
Keith, your to carnival.
And.
[APPLAUSE].
>> Game over.
>> I don't know why, what happened.
>> When the game is over,
we can talk about the experience, what it
felt like being a salesman.
And that is something they get.
>> I think the system is faulty.
>> It must be.
>> [LAUGH].
>> I love learning.
Our planning was impeccable.
>> We crushed them.
>> [CROSS-TALK].
[MUSIC].
[BLANK_AUDIO].